all right but we got to begin with the
news here the growing showdown the
growing showdown between republicans and
big business over the gop's efforts to
change voting laws in the wake of the
2020 election major league baseball has
announced
it is pulling this year's all-star game
from georgio
over one such law in the state so let's
remind folks about what that law does it
shrinks the window for sending absentee
ballots
severely limits the number of ballot
drop boxes
and gives more control of local
elections to state lawmakers who are
majority republican
it also makes it a crime to give water
or food to people waiting in line to
vote
there are also less controversial
elements like expanding early voting so
that there are at least 17 days to cast
a vote
and it can go up to 19 days if counties
choose to offer two sundays of voting
the bill also requires that when lines
are longer than one hour
counties must send more staff and
machines out a number of big businesses
in georgia though including delta and
coca-cola have criticized the law
leading republicans to threaten
retaliation for more on all of this we
are joined now by atlanta mayor
keisha lance bottoms mayor bottoms good
morning to you
a complicated morning for you i imagine
because this is somewhat
divided democrats on the one hand you've
got joe biden
president biden supporting the move by
major league baseball but stacey abrams
prominent democrat in the state says
while she commends major league baseball
she's disappointed about the
impact this move could have on families
there in the atlanta era
atlanta area where are you on this this
morning well first of all good morning
and thank you for having me
you know this is a tough one the metro
atlanta economy
is the 10th largest economy in the
nation
and so when you talk about boycotts in
and around
atlanta and the state as a whole it's
impacting small businesses it
impacts corporations that hire not just
corporate officers
but administrative assistants people who
clean up the building work in the
cafeteria
and so i respect the decision i
understand the decision
but i don't like the fact that we have
been put in this position
by our state legislature and our
governor
because the people of georgia will
suffer
yeah mayor bottoms you've said that
other dominoes may fall as a result of
this law in your state have you heard
from other companies
who have already signaled that they're
not going to do business in atlanta or
in the state of georgia because of it
well i do know that there are other
large-scale events that
are are openly contemplating whether or
not
they will stay in our state tourism is
one of the largest industries in our
state delta airlines is one of the
largest employers in our state
so this will have a devastating impact
and the irony of it
is that we were opened up early
under the name of getting back to some
type of
economic recovery and with just one
signature
that's all been wiped out and so it's
not too late
for the governor and the legislature
legislators to go back
do something differently they can go
back in january
they can fix this very broken and
ill-conceived law or they could perhaps
can even go into special session
over the next few months and make tweaks
that will allow us to continue to be the
the open and welcoming state that we
claim to be
well the governor mayor bottoms good to
see you the governor and republicans in
your state legislature do not appear to
be break
do not appear to be backing down they
say they are standing firm
are you worried that this will now
backfire against your state in your city
i'm absolutely concerned that this will
backfire this is the first
of likely many events that we will see
pull from our city and from our state
and also again we are home to almost 30
fortune 500 companies
in the metropolitan atlanta area an area
that voted very heavily uh democrat
uh back in november and in january
and so it is it's unfortunate we
we've had laws contemplated in the past
that
that people threaten boycotts but we've
also had governors
in the past who vetoed those laws and
this governor has chosen not to do so
instead he's doubled down
so so mayor how would you like
corporations and businesses to respond
to this issue
well what you've seen is a response from
corporations and businesses
but it's hurting the city potentially so
what would you what if anything would
you like them to do
well just what corporations have done
they have spoken out
and said that they support access to
open voting
uh and that this law is is not a good
law for our state
as a whole i think that at this point
that is all they can do
but there is well actually there is a
little more
i know many corporations have already
said that they will not
support candidates uh with financial
support
who supported this law and so it it
looks like it's going to be a very long
and painful fight all the way around but
again
there's an opportunity to fix this you
have to know when the whole you have to
know
when to fold this is hurting our state
the economy of our state
and that's not good for anyone no matter
what side of the owl you are on
mayor keisha lance bottoms thank you
very much for being with us this morning
we appreciate it